engage God mode because we're about to
embark on the worst first week of work
ever worse day ever
yes black nears smithereens is a tense
story about the dangers of technology so
in this video we'll be going over its
ending and if you want to skip right to
the Easter eggs I've left a link in the
description below the very last shot of
the episode is of Billy Bauer's eye
which is in direct contrast to the first
shot of the episode which is of
Christopher Gill Henny's the entire
episode revolves around these two men
Chris wants to get in touch with him and
the irony isn't lost that the man who
founded a company to keep people in
touch is one of the hardest to get in
touch with he's on a tenday no
technology retreat the eyes however
become a recurring motif throughout the
episode we see them in several close-ups
and Frankie Valli in the four seasons
can't keep my eyes off of you plays off
and on while in the car what Chris can't
keep his eyes off is his phone at least
as of three years ago back in 2015 when
he was responsible for the death of his
fiancee Tamsin he couldn't keep his eyes
off his phone and for a brief second
took his eyes off the road which
resulted in a deadly crash Chris was
lucky and survived with the other driver
taking responsibility because he had
alcohol in his blood now Chris has to
live with the guilt of killing the only
thing that mattered to him it's after
this tragic event that Chris completely
cuts himself off from social media you
can see here his last post was in 2015
right around the same time of the
accident
the years of guilt built up in him until
he couldn't take it anymore this is when
he takes matters into his own hands and
kidnaps a smithereens employee with the
intent of holding him hostage so he can
get in touch with Billy one of the great
things this episode and many other black
mirror episodes does is withhold
information giving us a sense of mystery
why is Chris kidnapping this employee
what does he want with Billy is this
some sort of revenge in this way we're
treated like the cops only given as much
information as they are is the gun real
what does Chris want from Billy what are
his motivations this tension continues
to ramp up until the final reveal but
watching the episode a second time with
the knowledge of what Chris will
eventually do gives us a lot of insight
into his character and why he does the
things he
for example we now know that what he's
trying to cope with is the guilt of
killing his fiancee and the other driver
this is shown when he tries to meditate
to suppress the flashes he experiences
of that tragic night we also see him
attend group therapy sessions but as he
says to the woman he later hooks up with
he hasn't mustered the courage to talk
to the group yet and that's because he
isn't ready to tell them that he's the
one responsible for the death of his
fiancee
the irony of Kris using an electronic
app to lure his victims is also quite
clear especially since we see him in a
local restaurant being triggered by the
sights and sounds of people on their
phones but part of the challenge of
writing a character like Kris is even
though he does bad things how is it were
still able to connect with him and get
caught up in this story part of it is
because we know Kris isn't that bad of a
guy he lets the first woman who gets in
his car go because she's not a
smithereens employee and he almost lets
Jayden go when he finds out he's just an
intern his first week on the job this
conflicted nature shows deep down he's
not a ruthless killer he doesn't want to
hurt a kid or put them through this
trauma he even lets Jayden out of the
trunk and into the backseat a move which
results in him getting chased by the
police Chris also asks a favor of Billy
he wants the password for Chrissy
Blackwell's persona account so he can
give it to the woman whose daughter
committed suicide in her group therapy
session she talks about how she grieved
for her daughter but it was the anger of
not knowing why she did it that got to
her if only she could get into that
account and maybe find some answers it's
this woman who also asks Chris out for a
drink saying why tomorrow you might die
tomorrow foreshadowing Chris's death
this is the big reason why I think Chris
was in fact shot and killed at the end
of this episode combine that with the
look on Billy's face after he gets the
news and how it would make for a tragic
fulfillment of this character story
Chris is most likely dead and Jayden
will have survived the ramifications of
suicide is also explored in this episode
but more so from the perspective of the
families Chrissy Blackwell's mom is
consumed by her daughter's death and
Jayden risks his life to retrieve the
gun from Chris so he doesn't kill
himself because he knows how the death
of his uncle by suicide affected his
family it's only after
has told Billy the true story that he
finally feels free to go through with
killing himself he's lifted this burden
off his shoulder and although he knows
the accident was his fault there is
still blame to be shared with Billy and
his company Chris talks about how Billy
designed his platform to be addictive
Billy even refers to it as a crack pipe
with Chris going on to say I heard that
you make these things that way
addictive there's a whole department at
smithereens devoted to engagement and
Billy feels like everything is out of
his control the smithereens that he
created in 2008 isn't what it is today
it's morphed into something bigger than
himself but that does not excuse the
fact that Chris was the one who looked
at his phone when he shouldn't have no
one forced him to do it but for Chris
the addiction was too strong the whole
point of lock mirrors to hold a mirror
up to society many of the messages in
the episodes are warnings and
smithereens is no exception
according to the National Safety Council
last year a staggering 1.6 million car
crashes were reported as a result of
cell phone use resulting in over 390,000
injuries technology is great but we must
always be cognizant of its dangers even
the name smithereens is a reference to
Chris's head being blown to smithereens
at the end of the episode all the events
in this episode a direct consequence of
technology but now for the fun part
where we dissect all the Easter eggs
littered throughout the episode and
smithereens has a ton so I'm gonna go
through them quite fast on Chris's hitch
tap right near the beginning we see
references to past Black Mirror episodes
like the Bandersnatch theater fences
pizza from season three's crocodile
Raymond from men against fire situ Gemma
arcades Redfield theater Redfield the
last name of Cooper Redfield from the
play test episode doll shoes a
supporting character from haded in the
nation Huck Shop Konnie Huq who is
creator Michael broker's wife Dawson
burger bar Dawson being a character from
season fours black Museum episode and
also skylane Street a reference to
victorious Golay in the main character
in season two's white bear in the
smithereen offices when Jayden tries to
get hold of his boss we get this shot of
reception which is
chock full of goodies starting on the
left-hand side we see a bunch of
hashtags snout rage goes back to season
1 episode 1 where British Prime Minister
Michael callow
has to have sex with a pig in order to
save the much beloved Princess Susannah
we also have to Saito gamoo hashtags the
Japanese gaming company dedicated to
creating immersive gaming experiences
which can be seen in season 3 episode
twos play tests they are apparently
announcing a collaboration with Netflix
also the platform which black mirror
streams on beneath that is hashtag
Ashley Oh Wembley Ashley OH being the
mega pop star in the next episode who is
performing at Wembley Stadium in London
and to the right you can see her tweet
or smithereen that says ready for fire
tonight Ashley OH X back on the left is
a reference to two British shows bargain
hunt and goggle box The Sea of
Tranquility reboot which can be seen in
Episode three of the seasons which is a
reference to the movie these cosplayers
are going to in season 3's nosedive we
have the delete persona hashtag persona
we see in this episode as the platform
Krissy Blackwell's mother is trying to
gain access to persona is the black
mirror equivalent of Facebook and this
situation was mimicked in real life when
two German parents took Facebook to
court in order to gain access to their
daughter's account to see if she died by
suicide or not the court backed the
parents stating that it follows under
current inheritance laws but was
overturned in 2017 when the appeals
court ruled that any contract between
the daughter in the company ended with
her death and could not pass on to the
parents by the way smithereen is like
our Twitter hence the hashtags Tucker
here is interesting and could mean
several things for example TCK our
systems the neural research and
technology company featured in San
Junipero and black Museum it's also the
name of the club in San Junipero there's
also Tucker soft which is named after
Mohan Tucker from Bandersnatch we also
have seen juniper strike which is a
hospital featured in Bandersnatch and a
reference to San Junipero on the right
in giant Twitter like text we have UK n
news which we've seen reporting in
previous black mirror episodes and
another not to Prime Minister Kalos
negotiations with the EU in Brussels a
reference to Theresa May and brexit just
below it we have a message from Saito
Khemu stating six hour warning can you
wait likely
having to do with citing emmos big
announcement later on in the episode we
traveled to Los Gatos which is
coincidentally where Netflix
headquarters is located on the
receptionist smithereen account we get a
few hashtags on the right which can
barely be made out the first is the
system which is from season fours hang
the DJ the system was the program that
paired couples with in over 99% success
rate now if only I could get one of
those hotshot is the TV show from season
ones 15 million merits
Clayton Lee from black Museum compliance
the drink from 15 million merits that
makes you compliant and granular the
company behind the robot drones from
hated in the nation it's now time for
speed round I'm gonna finish it off in
the speed round where we name off all
the references in this smithereen
employees phone carlton bloom the artist
from national anthem Kari and Clayton
leave from black Museum Cooper from play
test daily from USS Callister dr. Peter
Dawson from black Museum do Danny from
USS Callister Greta from white Christmas
Hector from shut up and dance
Ian one of the murderers from white bear
Jaime from the Waldo moment karen park
from hated in the nation kelly from san
Junipero Kenny from shut up and dance
Lisi from nosedive liam from the entire
history of you Martha from be right back
Matt from white Christmas Prime Minister
Michael callo Nanette and Nate Packer
from USS Callister in ishtam main
character from black Museum and I'm
pretty hungry after saying all that so
here's some fences pizza on Chris's
smithereen account we see that Chris
posted way back in 2015 which of the
news site to gamma consoles should he
get UK n reporters arriving on Chris's
language analytics page there's another
reference to Michael callow victorious
Killeen and space fleet from season
fours USS Callister also a nod to
Charlie Brooker show 2014 white ukn
online has an article about Chris's
accident but look over at the side here
B population in serious decline a
reference to season 3's hated in the
nation another PM Callens introducing
the cookie which can be seen in the
white Christmas episode and is the name
given to the device which digitally
replicates the consciousness of a human
being
we have black male victim found dead in
car it's likely a reference to season
threes shut up and dance in which black
male victims were forced to do crimes or
risk their secrets being brought out
into the pub
and a company recording everything you
say sounds a lot like smithereen which
is able to listen in on Chris's
conversation whoo that was a lot of
Easter eggs I hope you enjoyed this
video make sure to give it a like and
subscribe because I have more videos on
the way you can reach out to me on
Twitter at thanks very whitey and
remember daddy loves you very much